deuxième deuxième facteur géopolitique
une fois encore qui révélée par
l'Ukraine mais qui préexistait c'est le
sud c'est c'est que à partir du moment
où il y a
la désoxydantation arrive il y a les
plaques tectoniques géopolitiques
bougent l'Est se croire l'Ouest diminue
il y a un espace pour les autres et les
autres c'est ce que Poutine appelle le
sud global c'est un peu évidemment ça ça
recouvre des tas de réalité différente
mais c'est une vraie réalité les
puissances qui sont ni à l'Est ni au ni
à l'ouest se disent pour beaucoup
d'entre elles on a une carte à jouer
voilà on a une carte à jouer qui est
autonome elle s'émancipe souvent de la
tutelle américaine du temps de
l'Occident vainqueur mais elle est donc
elle s'émancipe elle est plus forte
qu'avant parce que la mondialisation a
profité au sud et
quand on lui demande de choisir elle est
plutôt vers elle choisit plutôt à l'est
et ça ça doit nous poser des questions
ça donne poser une question pourquoi
alors pourquoi pour on pourra reparler
je je vois pas aller trop loin troisième
facteur
je réduis encore une fois plus la focale
l'Afrique dans le sud il y a l'Afrique
l'Afrique c'est un sujet particulier
d'abord pour nous européen parce que
c'est en face de chez nous c'est comme
un continent en pleine exposition
expansion démographique et qui en plus
en crise économique structurelle en
crise sociale politique sociétale enfin
je veux pas vous passer nous on a à la
FM es Descartes sur le bassin
méditerranéen qui montre que quel que
soit le critère qu'on prend que ce soit
l'économie la démographie
l'organisation sociale le traitement des
femmes le covid la corruption etc on a
toujours la même carte le Nord et le Sud
et quand on la compare avec les années
passées les couleurs divergent chaque
année un peu plus c'est-à-dire qu'en
fait au lieu d'avoir ce qu'on avait
prévu du temps du processus de Barcelone
dans les années 90 cette convergence des
deux rives et je vous ai expliqué
finalement cette Europeanisation de nos
voisins qui se faisaient quasiment
mécaniquement la question était de
savoir comment on allait gérer ça en
douceur c'est plus c'est pas tout ça ce
qui se passe ce qui se passe c'est une
divergence doublé d'un antagonisme d'un
ressentiment très fort et et ces
structuré de faire quoi il y a aucune
raison que ça s'arrange tous les
paramètres et l'Ukraine la guerre du
crâne le covid les crises économiques
diverses et variées la pandémie fallait
pandémie à venir
tout et le réchauffement climatique bien
sûr j'aurais du conseil comme ça tous
les paramètres qu'on voit au taux
extérieur qui agissent sur cet
environnement
selon toutes les analyses n'auront comme
un effet que d'accroître la divergence
entre ces deux rives et ces deux rives
elles sont elle est à notre
directe proximité